turkey needs to drum up customers the
country is struggling to improve its
image in light of bomb attacks in
Istanbul and a tense political situation
German tourists are increasingly
reluctant to visit what's traditionally
been a favorite holiday destination
that's why crisis management is in order
at this year's ITB trade fair yes mean
Taylor found off button tour operator JT
touristic is here with moonshee Cara
kaya the manager of her Turkish partner
company
bookings have actually declined enormous
ly I have to say the attack in Istanbul
January especially because it happened
to German visitors really threw us Bank
a lot Yasmine Taylor founded JT
touristic six years ago and now has 65
employees the travel agents place orders
on a daily basis with their partner
companies in the destination countries
that is as their customers requests come
in rather than buying up allotments
ahead of time that flexibility means a
lot to the company head then the bombuh
open vorpal if a bomb goes off anywhere
in the world we notice it immediately
because people stop booking that
destination or are very cautious attacks
and terrorism warnings in Egypt Tunisia
and Turkey for example have caused
bookings by German vacationers to drop
by 40 percent since the start of the
year all those countries are heavily
dependent on tourism
but judging by experience yes mean
Taylor doesn't expect demand to stay low
for too long at the moment booking times
are getting shorter and shorter and
we're seeing a shift in destinations
there are a lot of bookings in Europe in
Spain in Portugal but Turkey is coming
back slowly we can't do without Turkey
the tourism industry is hoping that the
situation in Turkey and other affected
countries improves soon and as mean
Taylor will drink to that